What is beautiful?
My glorious, lovely people.
My God-given name is Rich Roll.
Once again, I'm here joined in Vulcan mind meld
with my sign wave sibling, Adam Scolnick,
waterman, writer, lover,
not my lover, just a lover in general.
So far.
How's it going?
Yes, so far, we'll see.
Our relationship is developing.
If you're gonna put it that way, then you're right.
Yeah.
How are you?
I'm good, man, before we get into all of that though,
let's just do the prefatory stuff.
For those of you who are new,
"Roll On" is the special limited edition version of the show
where Adam and I prognosticate
on matters contemporaneous, matters current,
confounding, complex, self-evident, non-obvious, obvious.
We typically buttress all of that
with a bit of other shit you should know,
we share a few wins of the week.
We round it all out with some listener questions
that we answer, if you are interested in that,
throwing your hat in that ring,
you can leave us a voicemail at 424 235 4626.
With that out of the way, Adam, how are you?
I am really good, life is good,
no complaints.
Wait, I'm not supposed to start that way.
A gentleman always wears a jacket to podcasts.
I'm not only wearing a jacket, I'm wearing tie-dye
because I just got off my shift at Ben & Jerry's.
I know it's a conundrum.
You're a contrast, it's confusing.
You've got the formal jacket, but then the Hippie T-shirt.
Well, that's my thing, I am a walking contrast in styles.
That's what I'm going for.
That's the intention behind all of this.
You know how everyone's like.
Just when you think you've got a grip on Adam.
Yeah, it's just like everyone is going
with like the cool, like understated tie-dye,
the new tie-dye.
I went with the audacious, like Ben & Jerry's tie-dye.
Phish.
That's where I'm gonna phish, exactly, phish with a P.
Phish meets I don't know what,
Brooks Brothers, Wall Street, what's going on?
Yeah, it's like, if Trey Anastasio did take that job,
did take that job instead of pursuing his life's passion.
But still, he was holding on to that sensibility.
If phish only became like a bar band
in the East Village,
Right, well, they worked Wall Street jobs during the day.
Yeah, I think they've chose the right career,
the right career path.
Trey Anastasio, shout out.
Who is right.
I think that's the second time his name has come up.
But when did it come up?
Maybe with Jess Lahey.
I can't remember, his name came up previously.
I once saw a Phish show at a gym in Vermont
in like '91
and that was a first time.
And so, it was pretty early days for them.
And then they became, of course,
the second biggest jam band ever.
When I was in law school in Upstate New York,
it was all about Phish like '90, '92 to '94.
Yep, started growing.
Big time Phish community.
Upstate band.
We were talking about music later in the show.
We are.
So, we're already getting into the bands.
I know, but go ahead.
Tell me about what's been going on
with your latest swimming escapades.
Oh yes, I--
By the way, Hank Wise wants to get all up in your kitchen
and involved with.
Hank Wise.
He left his voicemail.
We're not gonna answer his question today,
but I appreciate that Hank reached out to a friend of mine.
And I appreciate that he was giving me permission
to wear my own mask.
It's exactly correct.
And he wants to go for a swim and I'd love it, man.
But he was talking about great white sharks,
if later in that voicemail.
And so, basically, I don't know if he saw it
if people who follow me on Instagram,
I posted the second time now,
I've been out with Carlos G the Malibu Artist
at where one of my swim spots,
not the one I go to to dive,
but just an open water swim spot,
which has been known, it's also a surf spot.
And it's kind of known to have
kind of a shark nursery offshore.
Well, he has been there now twice, two weeks in a row.
The first week he flew, when we were in the water,
he saw a shark, but we were about getting out of the water.
This time, there was a 10 foot white shark,
30 to 50 feet from me while I was swimming.
And the funny part of that is he has a whole protocol.
So if you're swimming and all of a sudden
you hear the drones zoom by your head
and then it's hovering and then you stop and you look
and it's hovering above the water,
there's a shark right beneath.
That's his signal for get out.
That's his Signal.
It's not a get out now because in this case,
the shark was between me and the beach.
That's not good.
(Adam laughing)
And the best part was
he was flying right near Listaner Paddler,
who had no idea what was going on.
So, Listaner Paddler
is all of a sudden trying to swat the drone,
not really, but like, he's like annoyed by the drone.
So, were you at Zuma?
Where was that?
No, this was Temescal.
So, the shark,
there is a storm drain just south of the Bel-Air Bay Club.
And that's where the shark was.
So, I had been swimming
and I just started to do some intervals.
And so, I'm splashier 'cause I'm trying to go faster.
At least the way I do it, it's splashier.
And all of a sudden I see the drone,
I hear the drone, I see the drone.
And I'm like, "Splashier is not a good idea right now."
So, I just stopped for like a minute and watch.
And then I though, and then he shot the drone up,
which is his signal that he's lost the shark
and he's looking forward again.
And I just thought, okay, well, I'm here to swim with them.
And the reason is, I know it sounds stupid
and even me, when I saw the drone hovering there,
I thought, okay, this was a cute idea, but now it's real.
And you know, but why am I doing it?
And the reason I'm doing it,
and the reason I've always been okay to do it
is because these sharks have been there.
It's not like they're there because we're there,
they've been there.
Well, all over sudden they showed up,
they've been there all along just our ability
to detect them has improved.
Right, and so they've been there
and there is no, as far as I've researched,
no history of attacks in that area
they're not looking for us.
There are dolphins that come by, they're looking for them.
There are sea lions, not in that spot,
but there are dolphins.
So, I've always known that.
And so, my feeling is that they are not interested in us.
That's the point of what Carlos is doing,
I mean, yes, there is a danger there,
but what he's doing is not what shark week does,
which is to sensationalize a lot of stuff
and, oh, you might get attacked, you might...
Even though this guy's involved
in "Shark Week, I love Sharks,"
and they wanna push a shark conservation narrative.
And he does too.
And so, what he's doing
is raising awareness that they're there
and it's not like you shouldn't be mindful of it.
He's not suggesting that,
but he is showing that the odds are low
that you're gonna have a problem, and extremely low.
If you think about how many people are in the water
and how close they are on a regular basis,
he did a drive up the coast from Malibu to Ventura.
And he saw over 20 in one day.
Right off, right behind the waves.
So, this is not a new phenomenon.
Right, but still, that may be his intention.
But when you see the image, it is you know you have,
a very kind of like guttural physical reaction to it
because that fucking shark was big.
And it was legit.
And it was not that far away from you.
And so, I just don't know
how you get back in the water and swim relaxed.
Like you can do it and rationalize it
and say, they're not interested in us
they're offshore, maybe he's there, maybe he's not,
is this an enjoyable exercise for you?
Because for me, I just start getting preoccupied with that.
And it's very difficult for me to just enjoy myself
and kind of let go.
Well, I'm gonna do, because I posted it in stories,
I'm gonna do a proper post and talk about it.
But so my feeling is when I was in the water,
yes, I was with you, I was all of a sudden,
my antenna was up and I wasn't so relaxed,
but my heart rate didn't really spike or anything either.
And I will go back to that spot and swim.
And because I'm just not that worried
about getting hurt, so--
And people should know like Temescal,
this is the beach that extends from the Palisades
to Santa Monica, is a pretty trafficked beach
where the Bel-Air Bay Club,
like all of these like beach clubs are along there.
Like there's a lot of the sand is very wide there,
but there's a lot of people in the ocean in that area,
it's not an obscure, hidden beach
by any stretch of the imagination.
Surf break is right there.
It's probably the busiest surf break
in the entire LA County I would think.
Maybe Topanga.
That or Topanga.
And they don't know, they're not familiar
with how many are right there.
We saw one time, April and I were driving back
from Malibu and we were driving right along
that where the highway comes right up
above the kind of Rocky ledge
that leads down to that surf spot.
And we saw a white shark.
I saw a splash, she'd seen the white shark breach.
And this time, while we were getting ready,
I was getting suited up.
He said he saw a white shark breach, he was certain of it.
I didn't actually see the splash that was facing him.
And so, I knew going in that there was a shark there.
So, it's not like I didn't know.
And so, I knew going in,
but I still had a very relaxed opening part of the swim.
When I saw the drone, I'm not gonna lie
obviously, I did feel like nobody wants to do it again.
So, if the shark was between you and the beach,
how did you get back to land?
So, I continued my swim,
which is, I tend to swim three to 400 yards off shore.
So, my first part of the swim is to go out
and then I go along the coast.
And then there is a buoy off of the Bel-Air Bay Club
that if I'm just gonna do like an 1800 yard swim,
that's kind of what I do.
And that's like a 35 minute swim.
And I swim around that buoy and I came back.
But this time I swam around that buoy
and I came back outside.
Well, how did you know
that you weren't gonna just run right into the shark?
Well, I wear a mask for a reason, Rich.
I didn't know, you never know.
I didn't bring up the mask by the way.
No, I didn't know but I came,
I just kept my eyes open and I just decided to,
at that point I decided to relax.
I've been doing it a while.
I've been swimming in the ocean very regularly, since 2012,
I've been in the water with big animals before.
I think I've gotten to a point
where I am not over it completely.
I don't think you ever get over the fact
that sometime it's good that boogie man
is gonna just flash in your mind.
And you're gonna remember
you're part of the food chain right now.
And there's nothing really you can do about that.
But for the most part, it's kind of out of me now.
So, I don't feel it, like when I show up at the beach,
I don't get nervous
I don't think about it on a regular basis.
All right.
So, I don't know, but nobody wants to be the guy
that gets eaten by a shark on YouTube, I can assure you.
No, nobody wants that.
And after that big speech, now all eyes on Adam,
if something should befall you.
Meanwhile, somebody jackhammering out here,
I don't know where that's coming from.
I hope that's not too distracting,
but suddenly we have like crazy construction
happening right outside our door.
Yes.
Anyway, tell me about this thing with Louis Pugh.
Lewis Pugh, Hall of Fame,
open water swimmer known mainly for his swims in Antarctica.
He's the first to swim in a riverine
like in a glacial melt.
He's a legend.
He is straight up.
We've talked about him before, haven't we?
We have, when he did the Antarctic,
the most recent Antarctica trip,
I think we talked about him.
He was planning and is planning
to swim the width of a fjord,
the mouth of a fjord in Greenland to raise awareness.
'Cause what he does
is he does these incredible open water swims
in freezing water, and he uses it as a platform
to then try to push for nations to align and change,
to solve the climate crisis.
And so, the plan was to be in Greenland with him
in August and do a story on his swim there.
And then his attempt to bring it to Glasgow,
to the UN Climate Conference
and to motivate other countries,
to get on board and start to fix these problems
because as we know, we have wildfires,
we have, I mean, every day you can find climate crisis news,
whether it's called that or not.
On July 27th, there was a melt in Greenland,
which is not the biggest they've ever had,
but enough to have covered all of Florida
in two inches of water.
That's how much ice melted in one day.
It's the third biggest, I think ever,
or one of the top three.
Anyway, we were gonna go do that.
Now, his swim is in Jeopardy
because the Delta virus has gotten into Greenland.
Greenland did really well
in the initial phases of the virus.
They didn't have many cases, they haven't had any deaths,
but they're only have 12 ventilators in the entire country
and Delta is already there.
So, they shut down commercial flights from Reykjavik,
which is the best way to get there.
It's very hard to get in there right now.
So, it's unlikely that I will go.
I'm hoping he still can go and do it,
but I'm waiting to hear and if I can make it, I'll be there.
Not for the times, right?
No, this is gonna be a long read.
So, it's like a long, deep dive story on Lewis
and his attempts to move the needle in Russia
and China, mainly Russia.
He's connected to a senator there, Sergey Fetisov,
who is a hockey legend.
And so, they've become buddies and trying to push Russia,
who tends to be one of the countries dragging their feet,
Russia and China have vetoes on a lot of this stuff.
And they drag their feet on a lot of climate issues
and they don't necessarily vote it down,
but they don't vote yes.
And so, you need a consensus on a lot of these issues.
So, he's pushing countries all over the world.
He's lobbying them,
if he can get Russia to move in that direction,
it'd be so huge.
So...
Yeah, that's cool.
He's been doing this for a long time
and there's nothing like performing a swim
in these crazy freezing waters
to unite opinion around the issues and create consensus
because who's not gonna celebrate
something like the things that he goes out and does,
and on top of that--
And he's extremely eloquent.
Yeah, he's like...
I don't is he a former lawyer?
He's he conducts himself like,
he's much more of like a statesman than an athlete.
Like he's an environmentalist first
and foremost, he's an activist,
but he's about consensus building and kind of
creating policy change at the highest level.
And not just sort of waving a flag and making a stink,
but actually getting parties together too.
Peace results.
He's an outgoer that swims.
Basically, yeah, that's good.
I should have a much easier way
of saying in certain respects, yeah cool.
Well, first of all, I hope that he's able to do it.
Second of all, I hope that you could find a way
to get there and cover it.
If they're not letting people into Greenland,
how many people live in Greenland.
So, they're letting like a thousand people a week in
which is--
Other more than that many people that want to get into.
Yeah, 'cause it's the summer season,
it's like people go, it's like there's cruise ship.
Like there's a whole business
and there's the people that live there,
but apparently all those flights are booked
and they're out of Copenhagen.
So, I'm waiting for him to,
he was gonna try to charter a flight,
he got approval for our charter to come in from Reykjavik,
but he did not get an approved for that,
or at least not yet.
And the clock is ticking because after September 12th,
it's extremely unsafe for him to swim there.
So, there's like a time where the air temp
is gonna get so cold that he wouldn't be able to recover
after a swim.
And the way they swim is gonna go,
it's gonna be about a kilometer swim each day.
And then he gets out and then he starts again the next day.
So, it's not a straight channel swim
'cause he's in a Speed and a swim cap
and it's 37 degree water.
Yeah.
So, you know, all that ice,
they talked about the melted,
it's going right into that (laughing).
Right, yeah, wow.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
More to be revealed on that show.
How are you man?
I'm doing okay,
I'm spaced out, man,
on my having trouble with my brain forming thoughts.
So, if I blank out,
it's all on you to carry this podcast,
I'm essentially kind of a little overworked
trying to get the next volume of voicing changed done
while also balancing everything with respect to the show,
going out of town tomorrow to Colorado for a wedding.
So, trying to get everything tied up
before I leave and Julie's already gone.
So, dealing with kids.
So, I'm a little frayed at the edges,
to be honest with you,
not leaving out my best self today, but I'm doing okay,
but I'm coming in to this podcast
a little bit fast and loose.
I feel like last time we did three hours
and the outline was very late in
and I felt very wed to the outline.
And today I'm like, I don't have time for this.
Let's just come into this and see what happens.
Yeah, jettison stuff.
Maybe it's better anyway,
just be more present rather than like staring at an outline.
Yes.
Not that we don't have some idea
of what we wanna talk about.
We're not pantsers.
We're not gonna read.
Not reciting scripts.
I did want to mention,
this is curious and interesting.
Okay.
The reaction to last week's podcast with Bruce Friedrich,
at least on Instagram,
in the comments below my Instagram post,
was like out of control.
Like they're almost, I don't know how 280,
maybe 300 comments below the post just saying,
this is, here's Bruce he's.
First of all, it's the third time
he's been on the show,
Right?
So, this is not new terrain,
but people had a lot of strong opinions about it.
There's a certain sector of the community
that felt like I have betrayed my roots,
that I should be talking about whole food plant-based diet
and getting people back in sync with nature
and talking about organic and non pesticide
and how can we live within the kind of cycles,
the circadian rhythm of the planet?
We should be focusing more on regenerative ag
and repairing our soil
instead of all of these new cultivated meat products
that are being called Frankenfoods
that are filled with chemical.
Chemical laden was a big kind of phrase
that got thrown around.
And I just think that...
We're doing (indistinct) points?
No, I think just because it's like,
oh, this isn't food
and they're making synthetic Frankenfood
and like what is this?
We should be repairing our soils.
Of course, we should be repairing our soils.
This is not an either or situation.
It's not a binary issue basically, yes.
We need to pivot towards more regenerative agriculture
and a way from factory farming and animal agriculture,
we need to repair our soils.
We should be eating organic.
We should be finding better ways
to grow food out of the land and make that accessible
and convenient for everybody.
At the same time, we're dealing with environmental problems
and sustainability issues
and issues around...
This is where my brain fog is coming in
no over like compassion, basically the suffering of animals.
And there's a gigantic swath of the global population
that essentially is subsisting on a fast food diet.
They're going to drive throughs
and they're eating the cheapest food possible.
So, the whole cultivated meat thing
and the innovations that are happening
in plant based meats, et cetera,
this is not being directed at people
that are already converted to a whole food plant based diet
or who are all about regenerative ag
or who are growing their foods.
This is only towards creating
an accessible cost effective convenient solution
that has a better ecological footprint
and is more compassionate than the current options
available to those people.
So, we need all of these solutions.
We need people looking at
how we create more nutritious food with less resources.
We need to figure out how to pivot away
from animal agriculture.
We need to do all solutions are needed.
And so, I just thought the kind of dialogue or debate
that was going on in the comments there,
it's fine, you know, have at it everybody.
But just to be clear,
just because I had Bruce on, doesn't mean
that I no longer believe in these other things
like I've had all I do is talk about
eating a plant-based diet or pivoting people
towards a more nutritionally dense foods
and all of the likes.
So, just because I have a conversation with somebody on
doesn't mean that I now am disavowing
the other people that I've had on the show.
Right.
It's a conversation, it's interesting
this is happening
It's actually happening world.
So, let's talk about it.
Help me to understand it.
And all these comments are from people
that clearly didn't listen to the podcast
because all of the things that they're concerned about,
I raised and we addressed.
Right.
So, anyway, it does affect me.
I really should like post and ghost
and not pay attention to this stuff at all.
Like I have this tension
because I want to be engaged in the community
and I do care what people think
is this one landing for people?
Is it not?
But ultimately like maybe we'd all be better off
if I just turned the comments off
or figured out a way to not look at them at all,
'cause just you know.
You don't want to turn it off
because the engagement is...
Is it hurtful for anybody, is it?
well, that's a good question.
I mean, you know, we get to that.
Does Anybody read, get into the comments
of anything on YouTube or Instagram
and go, my life is now better.
As a result of...
Every other day, I go on your Instagram site
and I try to pick a fight.
Do you, good how's that going for you?
(Adam laughing)
That I was, pro-free dressed.
It's pretty easy to do that, you can get into a fight
without even trying to get into fight.
I've four ghost accounts so, I can.
Now, I know what's really going on, okay.
I think it's good to, we need to
in general be able to have discussions with people
and about things that we don't agree with.
And if we can't do that, we will never advance and...
What's funny is that people say to me,
"Why you have all these people on that you agree with.
"Why don't you have people on that you disagree with?"
Okay, well, within reason,
like I don't need to have somebody on my platform
that I completely disagree with
and I don't feel merits that level of attention.
Right.
But then when I do have somebody on like, Bruce,
like I have concerns about cultivating,
like, what is this?
how is this gonna impact,
like I have legitimate concerns about that.
So, I have somebody on who,
I agree with a lot of what he has to say,
I've concerned about other things.
And then I get criticized for having somebody on
who doesn't align completely, perfectly 100%
with my values or the values of the listener.
So, what do you really want other people
that have different points of view
or do you want to tune in
and just hear somebody regurgitate,
like your worldview over and over and over again
to affirm what you already believe?
I think, both of those things,
but mostly it's the silo,
that's the problem with being siloed in.
So, I, what my point was is kudos to you
for inviting someone on
and the reason that you invited them on your platform
is 'cause you know he's got his point of view
is this could benefit everybody,
it's not just this could benefit me.
And listen if you're gonna solve problems at scale,
there's compromises with that,
you need to work within the system,
you gotta get Tyson, you got to get Cargill,
you gotta get these huge companies interested in this.
This is why I'm interested in Paul Hawken and aquaculture
and the benefits of aquaculture.
That's why I'm not,
when we had our Seaspiracy debate,
that's what this exact same place
I was coming from,
is like we do have to think, there are other people eating
and they're not necessarily all gonna be down
with the diet that you're choosing
and I choose most of the time.
You are not Kind of solve the world's problems
by brow beating people
and to changing their personal habits.
Right, and so,
you have to be able to feed those habits
to some degree, and you can move them.
It's like--
But you need to meet them with an alternative
that is just as convenient just as cost-effective,
It is just as good, is as nutritionally valuable,
and created with a lower footprint and all the like.
All that.
Right?
Yes.
But I don't know how we got down this rabbit hole.
The point is, I think the other point I wanna make is
that comments sections,
on social media sites are not necessarily a proxy
for the true audience temperature on a certain thing.
It's just people have strong opinions
they wanna voice them.
And whether that it truly reflects the majority
take on that podcast.
I think if you start to align those things,
you're going down some dark alleys, anyway.
There you have it.
I'm trying to give myself my own therapy on this.
Yes, and the good news is you're gonna tell your wife.
I am.
So, you know.
For a couple of days to get some fresh air.
Yeah.
All right, let's pivot.
What do we wanna talk about in duro corner?
Yeah, this is you Colorado.
This is where you're headed.
Well, we can just follow up
on two things that we talked about last time.
We've been keeping you up to speed
on Ravi Ballenger's Colorado crash.
For those that are new,
he's in the midst of this summer long quest
to conquer a variety of ultra challenges
that include the Leadville Marathon.
He then ran the Colorado Trail, which is 500 miles.
He did the silver rush 50 back in Leadville.
Now, he's in the latter stages
of summiting all 58 of the Colorado Peaks
that are over 14,000 feet called 14ers.
And he's done 33 as of yesterday,
we're recording this on Monday.
So, just 25 more or what have you.
And then he's gonna rock it out with the Leadville 100
to complete the whole thing and on August 21st.
So, seemingly having no issues and just out there every day,
taking cool photographs
of climbing all these mountains for him
driving around in one of those like sprinter vans.
As he sleeping in the van.
I think so.
I think they got it all kitted out.
Yeah, I've seen it, it's amazing.
Which is cool.
He's living it, man, he's on the mission.
I don't know much more to say other than that,
he's done 33 and he's continuing to kill it,
but we do have an update on Timothy Olson.
Since we last spoke, he completed the Pacific Crest Trail.
The FKT was achieved, fastest known time, he crushed it.
The previous record was Karel Sabbe.
I think that's how you pronounce that, from Belgium in 2016,
he did it in 52 days, eight hours and 25 minutes.
Timmy did it in 51 days, 16 hours and 55 minutes.
So, by a decent margin.
By about 16 hours or a little less.
We're talking about 2,653 miles
with 40,000 feet of elevation gain,
he's running 51.3 miles a day on average
for seven weeks straight.
Given all that, like that is,
he did crush the record.
Anytime you beat a record by hours, it's amazing.
But at the same time, it's like,
it was narrow enough to where like any one problem
could have trashy.
He railed it.
Yeah, if he had one significant problem
it would have jeopardized the whole thing.
No small feat, my friend gradually to me
should come back on the show and tell us about it.
Yeah.
I know there was some improvisations
due to trail closures in the like
where they had to like figure out
how to jockey around certain sections
that were closed and get to a different style.
I don't know exactly.
Because they're like wildfires.
Right, which I think is why the kind of official
F-K-F, I keep saying FTK it's FKT.
I make that mistake a million times.
I don't know...
'Cause it's a bad, if it's sort of FTP
or because of..
FTP, I don't know.
Yeah. STP, stone temple pilots.
It's because of STP.
May be because of that.
So, I don't know if it's official.
I don't know what makes it official.
Maybe it's pending right now,
but I think it will be official.
Meanwhile, his wife's eight months pregnant,
it's been this spiritual journey for him.
I mean, Timmy's a very soulful guy,
I think part of it was processing,
the kind of grief that they shared over two miscarriages
that they suffered through, but--
(indistinct) was one hell of a baby moon, bro.
I know, no kidding.
You've redefined the man, the man baby moon.
His coach is Jason Koop, who I know a little bit.
I met Jason when I helped crew for Dean Karnazes
at Badwater 'cause Jason helps coach Dean.
And Jason's a great,
he's just a great resource for wisdom
when it comes to endurance training
and he wrote a really cool kind of blog post
with his takeaways from Timmy's performance
'cause he coaches Timmy as well.
And I'll link that up in the show notes.
Beautiful.
Yeah, man.
What else?
Saif Saaeed, our friend that we met in Utah
during the Iron Cowboy final day.
He's the PhD student in AI, right?
That had never run a marathon and showed up
and just started banking marathons on the daylight.
He moved from Texas where he was studying
to Utah on his buddy's guestroom
and started showing up every day, and then--
He went back home didn't he?
He's not still hanging out in Utah.
No, he's back in Texas.
And his goal was after that,
he was inspired to do a 50 miler on his birthday,
which he did accomplish.
So, kudos, kudos Saif.
Cool, and on that note,
I think we officially have a date
for the Iron Cowboy coming on the podcast.
Beautiful.
He's gonna come down here, I don't remember when.
Not right away it's gonna be a little bit,
I think he's gonna come with Sonny too.
So, it'll be both of them.
Spectacular.
It should be cool.
He reached out when I posted the shark video,
the shark photo.
Oh he did, what did he say?
He said, "Is that real?"
Yeah, you gotta post that again
before this goes up because I was in a story
or you were just posting it at the Malibu Artist.
At the Malibu Artist, Carlos G at his,
his post, I shared that story so I will post properly.
Cool, all right, well, let's take a quick break
and we'll be right back with you should know.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome
but I wanna snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables,
seeds, beans, and lagoons into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plantpower Meal Planner
are affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just a dollar or 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.rich roll.com.
Promo code, RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
The big story today, We're gonna talk about the Olympics.
It's on everybody's mind.
Now, we're gonna attack it from the perspective
of mental health.
And we were joking, the break, Adam said,
"I want what you want Rich."
And I said, "You have a boundary problem."
What's a mental health issue.
You can't, yeah.
So, I'm, I understand that.
Yes.
But ultimately that's a path
towards unhappiness and misery.
If you think your being,
what you do is you delude yourself
into thinking you're such a good dude.
Like hop's such a good guy
because I don't really care what I want.
I just want everyone else to be happy
when you sublimate your needs or your wants
or your repressing them,
then ultimately you're just kind of creating a situation
where you're going to develop some resentments.
Got it, I don't fully supplement.
I don't wanna paint the picture that I don't do without.
You're very easygoing.
Yes and when I can,
I like to not think,
like for me we're gonna get into the mental health story.
We should probably set the table,
but we all know what we're gonna talk about.
For me though what I was trying to say
was I don't overly analyze my emotions.
I try not to, so I'm more on the stoicism side of things
when you come to that, like to me,
like it doesn't help my process
to dive deep into my own emotions
because I actually think emotions are often the liars.
Now, we're gonna get into the Simone Biles topic,
obviously, winner of 30 combined Olympic
and World Championships medals, best gymnast of all time.
If it's not her it's Nadia.
So, it's one or two, right?
It's probably her,
and she, the team was in the finals
and she had a bad vault.
And then she left the competition.
And because it's so rare to see an all-time great step back
from a competition in the finals
with a gold medal on the line,
it inspired a whole wave of analysis.
Right.
And one of those, what she was saying
is that it wasn't right for her mental health to continue.
That was the initial statement.
And she had to protect herself
and she stepped back and let one of the other girls step in
and they got a silver medal,
which is still Victoria's outcome.
But because it's so rare to see it.
Because we are all conditioned
for the stoicist idea of champions,
originally, there was this big outcry
of I've never seen someone quit on that stage,
blah, blah, blah.
And then there was the backlash to that
now, she's doing the right thing.
She's, taking a claim for mental health.
And so, it became this kind of
weirdly unmoderated debate
and the subject of many, a think piece.
And so, where were you when all this was going on?
What were you thinking about all of this?
Yeah, it's interesting.
And what's also fascinating about it
is that it became a partisan issue.
Like everything else, it became politicized
and your perspective on what,
Simone Biles decided to do your perspective on that
had to reflect your political ideology.
It does seem to a lot like me personally,
when I first saw it, the first thing I thought
is I've never seen an all-time great do that.
So, then I start thinking,
'cause I'm a skeptical journalist.
So, I started thinking, was she gonna lose anyway?
And she didn't want to lose,
this is a way to lose that without losing.
That's where I first went.
This is not a judgment on her,
this is just where my thought process was.
So, I thought that then I thought I do like it
when I did feel like she has a team.
It's not just an individual thing
that she's stepping back from, that's one thing.
She does have a team that's relying on her.
She's the leader of the team.
So, I did fall into that category, even though politically,
it doesn't seem like that should be the place
that I line up.
That was the first place I did go to
before kind of taking a step back and letting it settle.
And what kind of convinced me
to think of it differently was when it came,
she posted that she actually has
what they call the twisties, I guess in gymnastics,
she had the hips, she couldn't land.
If he can't land, you can't.
The way she described it is you lose your sense
of like space and time.
So, you're in the middle of a vault
near in the middle of the year.
And you don't know which way is up and which way is down.
And this got played out in those early,
I think it was at a vault or there was some attempt
where she intended to do,
I don't what it was like two and a half twists or whatever,
and only did one or one and a half
and landed kind of off kilter.
That was clear indication.
Like there was something going on here.
And I agree I think that original
kind of knee jerk sentiment
is sort of a boomer adjacent sentiment,
like us being older, right?
What do you mean you're gonna opt out.
The very definition of a champion
is the person who perseveres,
who demonstrates the grit
and when their back is against the wall
and everything stacked against them,
they move forward nonetheless, and either prevail or don't.
That's the conventional wisdom here
and I think what complicates the Simone Biles situation
is a couple of things.
First of all, when you're dealing with gymnastics,
you're dealing with very dire, physical consequences
if things go wrong,
it's not just, hey, I'm not gonna run this race
'cause I'm not feeling it.
It's like if I land wrong, I could land on my neck.
I could paralyze myself.
And I think second to that,
there is truth in that she was opting out
for the best interest of the team,
because if she wasn't gonna be able
to perform to her abilities,
then is that really in the interest of the team's quest
to win a team medal, right?
Yeah.
Would that be better filled by somebody else?
So, there was a self-sacrifice aspect to it.
And I think, look greatest of all time,
30 combined Olympic and world championship medals,
this is not like a wilting flower.
This is somebody who has a champion mindset,
who knows themselves as well as anybody,
the level of like self integration that you would have
to have to perform.
These routines that she does is just it's mind-blowing.
So, this is not somebody who is scared
of obstacles or difficulties.
So, when this person says, "Look, I need a break."
It's not like, there's a history of Simone saying that,
this is new so we should take it seriously.
It should be a benefit of the doubt type.
Who do you think wanted to win the gold medal
more than her, nobody.
Tucker Carlson.
Tucker Carlson wanted it for her more than her .
So, I love like cue Piers Morgan, who always has--
He was the first.
Yeah, it's like come on, dude.
Like all the peoples who had the hot take
of your wimping out are all couch potatoes.
Nobody who's well-versed in elite performance
had that perspective.
Everybody
from Michael Gervais to, I found a couple of links
like David Epstein, who's been on the show,
wrote in his Range Report a whole thing about this,
Brad Stulberg wrote an article for Outside.
Lindsay Crouse wrote a couple opinion pieces.
One of which quotes Steve Magness,
who's Brad Stulberg's writing partner.
Who's also been on, all these people have been on the pod.
They all kind of have the same perspective,
which is like, look, it gets confusing
because the celebration of what she did,
I think should be about the fact that
an athlete is taking greater control of their life
and not allowing their decisions to be dictated
by teams or organizations,
rather than we're celebrating the fact
that she's opting out.
Because it politicized.
And we can get into that in a little bit,
'cause I have a TED Talk I'd like to unleash upon you.
But because of that,
the way it played out there was this whole set
that wanted to make her hero out of it.
And was she did--
The lionization of like
taking the "easy way out."
The backlash to the backlash.
And the thing that just begun
had become she's a hero because she opted out.
Quit, however you wanna say it
because she took care of her mental health.
And that's weird thing for 50 something year old guys,
like that's a narrative I'm not used to.
It's first of all, it's ridiculous.
It's like, this was a personal choice she made
because she had her own calculus.
And part of that calculus has to be the fact that
the U.S. gymnastics has been a corrupt organization
that included child molester.
Yeah, she suffered abuse.
She was abused by Larry Nassar, the doctor,
she's one of the survivors.
There were dozens of girls that were abused
by this man who is now in prison.
And the day that she stepped back from doing that routine
on that day, five years earlier,
she actually went to Indianapolis for an event
to benefit us gymnastics.
And the guy that was showing around Indianapolis,
according to this report in Washington post
by Sally Jenkins, great analysis, which really changed,
started to change the way I looked at this.
To me, it's the one story
that felt like it had true insight
into some of the backstory of what was going on.
In that, that person knew about Nassar.
And the gymnastics organization knew about Nassar,
but didn't tell the gymnast about Nassar.
And in fact, let him let that still continue.
And so, that happened five years to the day
and one of the reasons she came back,
she said this to NBC reporter, Hoda.
I forget her, I can't...
Hoda, all you needed to know is about...
Hoda on today's show.
She said that if there weren't an remaining survivor
in the sport, they would've brushed everything aside
and probably had the same athletes,
still training at the Karolyi Ranch, in Texas.
She came back at 24,
which is an advanced agent gymnastics, as we all know,
and she did that to help change the sport.
And so, when you put all of that
into the pot and you stir it up,
you understand these demons are real.
It's like, that had to be part of the thing,
should I sacrifice myself right now, like for who?
And that had to be part of it.
And that doesn't necessarily make it open and shut case.
Because as of this taping,
she is going to compete on the balance beam.
She's going back out for one last routine.
So, she is going to do that in an individual balance beam,
but it had to be part of the situation
that led to this.
Sure, yeah, July 27 being this day,
in 2015, as you mentioned, that was the day...
Six years ago.
Yeah six years ago,
she was at USAID headquarters in Indianapolis
for a bunch of promotional appearances
and being accompanied by this guy
who was well aware of what was going on
and was working with an FBI agent
to like sweep it under the rug and promise
that that FBI agent would get some job with the IOC
or something like that.
I mean, this Washington Post article is pretty incredible.
Yeah, it's incredible stuff.
We'll link that up in the show and I was,
but yeah, it provides a much greater,
more in depth context
for what's actually going on.
And when you think about someones career,
now being an elder statesman,
which is hard to believe 'cause she's so young
and the care that she undertakes
to like mentor all of these younger athletes,
particularly, athletes of color,
which is so important to her compounded by this idea
of being an elder statesman who links the legacy
of Nassar to the current state of affairs.
Like that's a lot to shoulder.
Yeah.
And twisties, it's not her first time.
No.
When was it, there was some other incident
a couple of years ago where she had twisties,
it took her a couple of weeks to get over it.
And twisties are unique a track of your body position.
I guess, yeah.
I guess, I mean, I'd never heard of it before.
No.
But when you really evaluate it,
and contextualize the whole thing,
it's like she made the right decision for herself
and for the team and it's ballsy as fact
that she would make that decision,
given a greater awareness and understanding
of the consequences,
knowing it's gonna be this big, controversial thing,
knowing that it's gonna cause a media cycle
and a media frenzy.
But I think it takes a lot of gumption and guts
to know what's best for you,
make that decision irrespective of what the reaction
is gonna be and do it for the interest of the long-term,
as opposed to the short-term gains
that you might have reaped
by making a different decision, right.
There are all these case studies
of other gymnast over the years
who were pushed, pushed, pushed, pushed,
and we're competing with stress fractures
and broken feet and all kinds of stuff
and get the gold and then you never see them again.
Yeah.
So, what are we really talking about?
What's more important here?
Like getting the gold medal at this Olympiad
or Simone being able to compete for another four years
and be healthy and more importantly,
who gets to make this decision, historically is the team
or it's the IOC or it's the USOC.
And here we have Simone
standing on the shoulders of Naomi Osaka
and what she did last month or whenever it was
to say, like, "I don't have to be a pawn.
"I'm not a pony here to dance for you when you wish."
Like "I have sovereignty over myself in my career
"and I'm going to put my foot down
"and say I'm not competing, it's not right for me."
And they should the right to make that decision.
And we should respect and support that.
It's true, I separately.
I know everyone wants
to bunch Simone and Naomi together as like,
There there's a qualitative difference
doing press versus competing.
Yeah, one is doing press one,
literally can't land in her sport.
It's not like Naomi, all of a sudden can't make her serve.
But what unites them
is this idea of the athlete taking control
and doing it in the face of all these other pressures.
As a young woman.
Like how dare you judge Simone,
you don't know what's going on in her head.
You can't imagine the pressure that she shouldering
or her interior experience of being in Tokyo
and everything that's going on around her
with the whole world focused on her.
That's right, I think
the Brad Stulberg article for outside to me
also was another one to really highlight,
the David I've seen one's great too,
he talks about a gold medalist in the bobsled
who had then had to deal with figuring
what's my next act, who am I now,
which Simone referenced, after this mental health.
Yeah, and it all goes to like,
this is a conversation, sorry, I didn't mean
to step on your words,
but this is a conversation that we've been having
on the show for a long time.
That started with the weight of gold
and the Michael Phelps documentary
and this growing awareness around the reality
of the mental interior experience
of the elite athlete and kind of pulling covers on that
and helping people to understand
that these are humans beings.
And Burckle, Burckle was the first,
probably first person on your podcast
that brought this particular conversation up, right?
I mean, is that right?
Yeah, and we've had Alexi Pappas has talked to,
we've had tons of people talking about it.
And so, then, but Brad's article
talks about this concept of heroic individualism,
which is, that's why we worship athletes.
And he's like his point was,
there's an innate problem with worshiping the athlete.
And that is that you're buying into heroic individualism,
which is a game of one-upmanship
against yourself and others.
And everyone has that in Western societies, his argument.
It's, basically baked into Western society.
I know as a writer, I feel it,
I feel that for real,
I feel it in myself when I'm working on something,
I feel it in competition, even with friends
and I feel it and I don't feel good about it.
Like it's not a positive experience
and you feel like, you feel it,
you don't wanna really buy into it, but it's there.
And so, his point was she made the right choice,
but sometimes the right choice would be
to persevere through it.
So, this is a much more nuanced situation
and he looks at kind of the science on,
on depression and these mental health issues.
He's his is not the, you know,
she's a hero for not doing it,
or she's a quitter, she, he's not in that camp at all.
Yeah, it's the difference between,
it's like, if you're used to use running as an example,
it's the difference between my legs are really heavy
and super tired today and I don't feel like running
versus there's a sharp pain in my knee.
Like what is a good pain and what is a bad pain?
Right?
What is something to pay attention to
that's gonna,
wherein the right thing to do is to stop and go no further
versus when is this just a difficulty
that could be overcome through tenacity,
grit, perseverance.
So, that's hard to know when it's a splinter in your mind.
Sure, yeah.
But when you're an athlete at that level,
you know the difference,
trust me.
Right.
It's not like, oh, she's weak of will.
I don't buy into that, but the point is well taken.
Like I get that.
Yeah, no, but she--
But I think the fact that people just jump to this idea
that she was being fearful or lazy, I think is absurd.
Yeah, like, well, I jumped to that conclusion
that she was more like not used to losing
and therefore one to lose on her terms
and trying to control it that's where--
Or like, here's a convenient way to not lose.
Right.
You just opt out.
Right, so, I actually did think that
until I didn't know about that
'cause she didn't tell everybody,
she showed on her own stories,
her attempting to land on the pillow parallel bars.
And she was like facing down in the bag.
The initial and the press release was very brief
there was like, she's pulling out,
it's not due to a physical injury.
So, it was like, well then what is it?
That also makes you wonder who put that out?
Who in that organization put that out
and why did they put it out that way?
And like could they have taken care of her a bit more
in that statement or that come from her camp?
Like all these things you wonder
after reading that Sally Jenkins story.
But to me, like the biggest reveal of all this
is not necessarily her mental state
and what she's got to do for herself,
because I think when it comes down to it,
you're 100% right.
Especially, Simone Biles deserves the benefit of the doubt,
especially in all time, great.
If you're gonna worship athletes
then you have to give an all-time great,
the benefit of the doubt.
And like, if that's what this person needs,
then that's what that person needs.
Does that make her her hero?
Not necessarily, but it makes her human.
And so, that's the point.
And that's the tension, right?
Like we don't want our heroes to be humid.
And this is a conversation about recognizing
the inherent humanity in the elite athlete.
But also the Olympics is,
there is something to be gained from
and something to be said for
like holding people up a little bit higher
as benchmarks to kind of drive our own aspirations.
Like I want heroes.
Yeah, right.
So, heroes are cut out characters.
Like I have to appreciate that they're actually human
and they're flawed, but I think we all benefit
when we celebrate people who do amazing things.
I agree and that's part of what
makes your podcast such an a must listen to is,
'cause you're bringing in unknown heroes a lot,
or maybe sometimes it is a known hero.
Or even just but too,
if you let one of those heroes talk for two hours,
you're gonna understand and appreciate the humanity
and that they will probably tell you
what their weaknesses are, their securities.
And I'll make it seem possible for you
to be your own hero,
which is the whole point, right?
Like again.
Yeah, but the idea was Simone that,
because she's this great champion,
she is disempowered from making those kinds of decisions
for herself is wrong.
Like you can't opt out.
You're our hero, you're the world champion.
You're not supposed to do this.
So, I am projecting onto you a set of rules
that you must adhere to
in order to remain the hero in my mind.
And that's fucked up.
It is fucked up.
And the other fucked up thing
is that here we are human beings, social creatures
who have become social media creatures, right?
And that's what we're talking about in the Bo Burnham quote.
The backlash, to the backlash,
to the backlash the thing that's just began.
Exactly.
Six media cycles
within the first five hours of the story.
And until we actually heard
about the twisties a couple of days later,
when she posted it,
nobody actually knew why she quit.
Like no one knew like on the.
But that doesn't stop everybody from having their take
or opinion or Piers Morgan from getting up and bloviating.
And discord feeds discord
because yes, Piers Morgan and people on the right
had that take, but on the left, we do it too.
I mean the left rails against criminal justice system
and harsh sentences,
unless it's the cop that murdered George Floyd,
the right loves cops,
wants to make love to the constitution,
unless we're talking about the 2020 election
and insurrectionists on January 6th.
I mean it's everything.
It's just, what's politically expedient.
The narrative bends to the the political ambition.
Exactly, and personal freedom
for trans people is good,
personal freedom for anti maskers not good
or vice versa, it's one side steaks out of position,
the other screams and yells.
And on the left, you better screaming.
Well, yeah, the exact really the right way.
Because if you don't...
You're just a little bit out of step.
You're gonna get barraged.
You're gonna need torched,
and we need a new culture.
We need not only do we not wanna buy
into heroic individualism,
we need to replace this me, me, me, me,
with we over me.
And that's starts with conversations.
My favorite moment of the Olympics so far
are the two high jumpers from Qatar in Italy
who were both tied and they were given an opportunity.
"Do you wanna do a jump off?"
And one of you will be the true Olympic champion
or do you want to share a gold medal?
And they shared the gold medal.
They hugged and kissed and it was beautiful.
And it's like--
People love that and that's great
and that makes me feel good too.
But also back to the stoic kind of response.
Like if you are the gladiator, do you accept that?
You say, no, we will fight to the death
to figure out who's better.
I think Russell Crow in Gladiator
would have hugged him on Huntsville.
Maybe where their life was on the line.
The stakes were a little bit higher.
Higher stakes.
I do love that story.
that was a good TED Talk.
Thank you for my TED Talk.
Are you still,
there more points that need to be made?
I'm sweating now.
(Rich laughing)
I'm perspiring.
Listen, man, I think it's interesting
that this is all coming up in the context of the Olympics
because the Olympics is all about,
well, first of all, it's a globalist agenda, right?
It's globalist by nature.
This is the original global.
But is this not the one thing where the world can stop
and we can all celebrate together
and agree upon, celebrating these amazing human beings.
Apparently not, I guess,
well, I've never there hasn't been
this kind of discord in Olympic.
Well, I guess there always is.
1968, 1968.
That's not true.
We had in '68, we had a boycott in '80.
Yeah, '84.
So, it's always, there's been a political aspect
to all of this, but I feel like
now that's drilled down
into it's becoming even more
because of the way that the culture is.
The difference is now it's not nations
that are having political infighting
or leaders from oppressed groups within a nation
it's individuals over bullshit.
It's not like we're not even talking about
Black Power in 1968 at
a time when there was incredible oppression over there
and they actually risked their gold medals
and gave up their gold medals knowing they would do it.
We're not talking about 1968.
We're talking about a young woman
making a decision for herself.
And then it becoming a political issue.
Like that was a political issue.
This isn't a political issue, it really isn't.
And then it becomes one.
So, it's like, it's backwards.
And I think coming upon us to want
to like getting back to your comments, like listeners,
we gotta all be willing to have conversations
with people who disagree with us.
We have to, 'cause we're not going to get anywhere
in solving big problems unless we're willing to do that.
So, it's interesting.
The Olympics showed us another lesson there, but.
You know Simone Manuel, the swimmer.
Yeah.
African-American swimmer.
She (laughing).
Her first name's Simone, right?
So, everybody's confusing her with Simone Biles.
She had to tweet, "I don't do gymnastics."
With like clapping hands.
I did not know that.
And it has 42,000 likes.
That tweet to clarify, like no, I'm not the gymnast,
but I'm also like kick-ass Olympian, anyway.
Crazy.
I love the Olympics,
I would say that I've watched less of this Olympics
than any other Olympics that have ever been
since I've been alive, simply because I've been too busy,
which is kind of a bummer.
We're also, I don't have cable TV.
I don't know.
So, I got the Peacock app for our television
so, I could watch it thinking I'd be able to just stream
what everybody else sees and it doesn't work that way.
You know, NBC is a proprietary.
I ended up like experiencing the Olympics
through a bunch of clips, which was not ideal.
Oh really?
But there are a couple Olympic related things
that I think we need to talk about beyond Simone.
The first is, what is with this ROC bullshit?
What's the ROC?
The Russian Olympic Committee.
So, basically, Russia gets banned from the Olympics
for all of these doping situations
which emanate directly out of Bryan Fogel and Icarus
and all the work that he's done.
But they find this loophole,
this end run around the spirit of the law,
which allows all these Russian athletes to compete-
Individually.
As long as they don't play the anthem if they win,
they can even wear the colors on their sweatsuit.
So, what's the difference?
Like who cares if they don't the flag?
It's unbelievable, ROC.
It's the IOC kind of capitulating, I think.
Yeah, well, capitulating to like,
what is the real politic there?
Because the IOC is just horrifically corrupt
across the board in so many ways.
And really, truly never has had
the athlete's best interest at heart.
It really is a giant power and money play.
Like I don't even think,
I mean, there really wasn't public sentiment
for the Olympics to even occur when they occurred
because of Japan's contentious relationship with COVID.
I mean, I think most people would have preferred
the Olympics get pushed even further.
And the IOC, because of these broadcasting contracts
and the amount of money that was at play,
there's no way they weren't gonna go forward.
Also Japan, Japan was out a lot of money too,
if it didn't happen, right?
I mean, they share that burden I think.
Yeah, that's right.
But ultimately it was the IOC's call.
They have like ultimate authority over that decision.
My favorite part of the IOC
is that Japan apparently has come out that they lied
about their July weather in their bid
and the IOC didn't like examine, like just, they just--
Let's talk about that because,
this is like that Stanley Kubrick movie.
What's it called?
Where T. Boone Pickens is riding the atomic bomb
out of the--
Oh yes.
How I learned to love the bomb.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's like you think these people are adults
and are conducting themselves
with some level of respectable decorum
and you find out like, it's just a banana republic
of corrupt influences.
Right.
It is like the 1920s still over there.
Like whoever, they don't read the report, it's like--
So, explain the Japan (indistinct).
So, apparently, July would--
I was happy.
We were even talking about going to Tokyo before COVID
and doing podcasts from there.
That was gonna be the first thing we collaborated on.
We both wanted to go to Japan,
I'm happy that the Olympics are in Japan.
I think it's awesome.
But in 1968, when Mexico City got the Olympics,
they moved the Olympics to early October.
If I remember correctly, late September, early October,
because of weather and weather patterns
and healthy air quality,
and Japan could have done that.
Like it could be in September when it's nice there.
It's late July when it's like 95 degrees
with 90% humidity.
And in their bid,
they characterize the weather as being sort of balmy
and not nearly as severe as it actually is
in order to secure the contract.
And because of the way television works in sports,
there's no way that they would have pushed it to the fall
because it competes with football.
Yeah, back in '68, that wasn't as much of an issue, yeah.
Yeah, so, it's all about TV, but it's so funny.
Then the IOC saying they never read the report
or they didn't really look into it.
They didn't vet it enough to realize,
like anybody who's been to Tokyo in late July
knows that it's unbearable.
It's like, would you do the summer Olympics
in Bushwick in August?
No, I wouldn't go to that.
Maybe July, they did the U.S. Open,
when did they do the U.S. Open?
Early September.
Right?
Yeah, that's when you should be doing in the humid areas,
the Olympics.
So, there's that,
what are their big athletes stories before we get into--
I mean, there's so many, obviously,
me being a swimmer, swimming is what I care about the most
and what I follow
to the extent that I was able to follow much of it.
And even then, this is the first Olympics
where I just really don't have personal relationships
with any of the athletes or the coaches.
I think maybe one or two of the coaches I've met in passing,
but typically, like I have friends
or people that I know quite well who are competing
or coaching.
This year I really didn't have that connection.
So, it made it less, you know, like I'm so busy.
It just was like, oh, who are these people?
I had to like learn who everyone was.
With a few exceptions, I mean, I think,
listen, this is the first in five Olympiads
where there's no Lochte or Phelps.
I mean, Katie Ledecky is the legacy of that era,
but you're going into a new,
it's a new generation of swimmers.
And that's talk about a heavy burden to live up to
without those guys around.
How are you gonna basically put points up on the board
that are gonna make people interested in what you're doing?
And with that,
Caeleb Dressel like showed up five goals, crushed it,
basically had the ultimate Olympics
that you could ever expect from that guy.
And it was just a pleasure watching him swim
and he set a world record in the 100 fly, right?
And also on the 4 by 100 medley relay.
So, that was cool.
And maybe for crying on the air.
Yeah, he did cry, he was emotional.
He's very handsome,
Leslie Jones has a crush on him, that's important.
Who doesn't?
How awesome is Leslie Jones and her Olympic commentary.
She's hilarious.
I know, she's so good.
And they tried to like mimic that
with Snoop Dogg and Kevin Hart,
which I felt was a little canned compared to her,
just very authentic, spontaneous.
She's like eating snacks while watching television.
Yeah, it's the best.
If you're not onto Leslie Jones and her Olympic commentary,
you gotta follow her on Twitter, she's like amazing.
So, yeah, I mean, Caeleb Dressel was amazing,
and it's interesting watching Katie Ladecky,
like I don't want to belabor all of this.
There's other places
where you can get a lot of Olympic feedback,
but I think that back to this issue of mental health
and the Olympics,
we can't discount the fact that all of these athletes
had to weather a COVID year
where their training was turned upside down,
where the predictability
of whether they would be competing or not
was very much in question,
like incredibly difficult when you understand
that at that level, to compete at the highest level,
to be that elite, you really have to know
like here's what I'm competing,
here's how I'm organizing my schedule
to be ready by that time.
And when all those dates are in flux,
and at least I know in swimming, like pools aren't open,
then they're open.
But then it's like, there's a lot of question marks.
And I think Katie being closer
to a later phase of her career,
I think it took a toll on her performance.
I think if the Olympics had,
if there had been no coronavirus
and the Olympics occurred last summer,
I think she would have swept her events
and would have been unchallenged.
But she did get better as it went along, right?
She did, yeah.
There was that, when they got the silver in the relay,
which one was that?
It was the 4 by 200.
Was it 4 by 200?
Yeah, I think so, I think so.
I don't think I watched that race.
And they became in silver.
So, I think she got the silver,
she got two silvers and two golds, right?
And in that race, they were far behind.
Like when she got into the pool,
she was over a body length behind.
I thought she was like 10 feet,
maybe two body lengths behind.
And to watch her almost reel them all in,
to me, that was one of the coolest swims I saw
this entire Olympics.
I was like you at the beginning,
the first four or five days, I wasn't paying any attention.
First of all, it's like,
by the time you turn on the prime time Olympics,
you're kind of like everything's already happened.
And unless you seal yourself from your phone,
you're gonna know a lot of the results.
In the past it's been easier for me to manage that.
Like the last two, London and Rio,
it's a little bit less of a time zone.
Problem is still there, but you can manage it.
In this case, I was like the first four or five days,
I wasn't paying any attention,
but I've slowly been wooed back in, even with no crowds.
It is sad watching the track, especially with the pool,
you don't see the crowds that much
'cause you're focused on the pool,
but the camera angle on the track, it's all the empty seats.
It is sad.
It is.
It's not the way it's supposed to be,
but I'm seeing Katie Ledecky do that swim.
And then afterwards, when they were asking her,
"Is this your last?"
I think it was her last event.
"Is this your last swim?"
And she's like, "I'm not retiring."
No, she's like, I'll be back in four more years, yeah.
Which I loved, and I thought she performed great.
Like again, it goes back to this idea
is anything but gold a failure.
And you know, maybe--
She has a great attitude too.
Always a smile on her face,
always a hug, always a nice, positive thing to say.
Really just acquits herself with such grace.
What a spectacular athlete.
I know.
Yeah.
Little curious aside.
So, she's from my club team in D.C.
She grew up in D.C.
and she trained when she was in high school
at the shitty pool at Georgetown Prep,
this private high school where our club team rents the pool
for pool time.
And that's where I trained all through high school
twice a day.
And I think they renovated it in the years
'cause obviously I'm like twice her age or whatever.
You guys both peed the same pool.
We both, yes.
Separated by a decade, probably.
I think the pool was renovated since I was there,
but this pool was just a toxic hazard.
I mean, it would drip like plaque tar from the ceiling
into it, and we would be like, if we get cancer
is probably 'cause we're drinking
whatever's dripping out of the ceiling into the water,
and you would go in there in the morning
and it would just be this cloud of chlorine vapor.
And because we shared it,
it was belonged to this high school,
we couldn't use the locker rooms half the time
because their students, we would like,
sometimes you could use the football locker rooms
and go in there, it's all muddy.
But for afternoon workout,
we would have to change in the pump room.
Like can you even get, it was just dirty and disgusting,
but kind of awesome to that
like you don't want the super nice pool
when you're grinding.
It's like the original Rocky,
you wanna be in the grimy gritty situation
so that when you finally qualify for that fancy mean
and you go to Indianapolis
and you see that incredible natatorium
and you're like, "Wow," right?
But you don't wanna train in that fancy place every day.
You guys are like the Hickory, like in Hoosiers.
You're like the team Hickory.
The word they makes me very uncomfortable.
Like I should not,
like I'm just saying I swam in the same pool as her,
like I don't know...
Good for Katie, she's the all-time GOAT.
Unbelievable athlete.
Shout out GW Preps' horrible pool.
I know.
Nice, how about Emma McKeon?
Australian medalist, seven medals.
Winningest female Australian swimmer ever, I think.
Yep incredible.
I think the winningest swimmer.
I mean--
Seven medals, four gold.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, the most medals.
Very few have gotten that.
I think, well, Caeleb got five gold
and the only other swimmers to do that are Phelps
and Mark Spitz and--
Biondi.
Biondi in '88, right?
In Seoul.
I mean, there's a speed skater, Eric Heiden.
Oh, Eric Heiden, my whole time.
They got it.
My all time hero, that guy.
Also cool to see some new faces.
We got Bobby Finke in the distance races, which he's a guy.
He started the converse of Katy.
Like he was somebody no one had really knew anything about
who really benefited from the extra year
to like hone his strength and endurance.
And he goes from like unknown to absolute legend
being the first American in 37 years to win the 1500
and then also wins the 800, which is cool.
Very cool.
Little sort of side anecdote with that.
Typically it's always been the 1500 meters for the men
and the 800 meters for the women.
There has never been until this Olympia
to 1500 meters for the women,
because historically it was considered
too difficult for women to--
Women can't swim that far.
Can't swim that far.
And the fact that it took until 2021
to rectify that is out of control.
Strange thing to think when a woman
was one of the first people swim across the English channel.
Anyway.
The IOC has been legendary for many, many years.
The last person, yeah, yeah, I know.
So ahead of the curve.
Yeah, they've always read things so well.
I do wanna spend a couple of minutes
talking about this guy, Michael Andrew.
I was to talk about him.
Who's to me kind of the most interesting,
curious swimmer on the U.S. Olympic team.
This is a guy who,
I've been aware of this guy forever
because even though he's, how old is he now?
He's like 22 or, he's pretty young dude.
Yeah, he's young.
But this is a kid who his entire life
has been expected to inherit the Phelps legacy
because when he was a kid,
he broke over a hundred national age group records.
Like he completely rewrote
all the national age group records as he grew up,
like basically breaking all of them.
So, more than any other swimmer ever has,
more than Michael Phelps.
So, the obvious expectation is like this guy
is the second coming, right?
He's gonna come in and he's going to crush.
And he failed to make the Olympic team in Rio.
I think he was like 17 at the time.
So, that makes him, I don't know, 23 or something like that
Is 22 they have quoted in his bio here.
Yeah, and what's...
So, he makes the team this year
and ends up on the 4 by 100 medley relay
setting a world record, so, gets a gold medal.
Yeah.
He doesn't medal in any individual event.
And what makes him so curious is the fact that
this guy has a very unique, original way of training
that contravenes all conventional wisdom.
So, most swimmers swim twice a day.
They're putting in anywhere
between 12 and 20,000 meters a day,
a lot of volume, plus dry lands and weight room
and all kinds of other stuff.
He is coached like homeschooled, coached by his dad,
managed by his mom, grew up in Kansas,
swimming in a pool in his backyard.
Like, didn't do the club thing
where you go and swim with other people,
like just basically was in the backyard with his dad,
this single lane pool that he trained in.
Now, they live in Encinitas, I think, in San Diego.
But he's remained kind of homeschooled,
and under his parents' control,
control is probably the wrong word,
but I mean sort of influence, yeah.
And his dad in conjunction with another coach
have developed this thing called USRPT,
which stands for Ultra Short Race Pace Training.
So, whereas most swimmers are training 12 to 20,000 yards
or meters a day,
he's swimming like 3000 a day, which is nothing,
but all of the training is that race, pace.
So, everything is like long busting, all out efforts,
approximate your race to the extent possible,
make the most of that compressed period of time
and call it a day.
The idea being that most swimmers
are putting in all these junk miles,
they're just swimming back and forth and the pool.
It's not really doing anything for them,
which is very controversial.
And it's interesting to think about,
because on the one hand, look,
this guy made the Olympic team.
He won a gold medal on the 4 by 100 medley relay,
he got fourth in the 100 breaststroke.
He's still early in his career.
So, he's had tremendous success.
But basically when I look at this,
particularly from an endurance athletes perspective,
I see a guy who,
actually I think,
and I'm not one to judge him, I don't know him,
but it would appear to me based upon his race performances
that he would benefit by increasing his volume a little bit.
Because if you watch his 200 IM,
the guy is like way ahead of world record pace at the 100,
at the 150, he's leading.
And then he goes 30 plus for the free leg.
Like he absolutely falls apart,
like in just an epic crash and ends up safe.
At the Olympics you rarely see somebody die like that.
And I see somebody who has no aerobic base
who can't sustain an effort over 200 meters
and Michael Phelps has commented on this.
He basically said, if you want to do well to 200 meters,
200 IM,
you gotta train the 400.
And I don't think Michael he's a sprinter.
The 200 is a stretch for this guy,
I'm sure he would prefer to just do 100 meter races.
But if you're gonna compete at the highest level
and the 200, like you gotta, it's...
even though it's a two minute race,
on some level in the context of swimming,
there is an endurance component to that.
If you wanna tap into a greater gear and bring it home,
there's no getting around the fact
that you've got to put in some volume training to do that.
I thought that you had said before that they stopped doing
those 10 to 12,000 yard workout days, isn't swimming.
Well, it is much more,
I think overall it is more race specific.
Okay.
So, there is a lot more quality, oriented training
that goes in, and I've just noticed that
from workouts that I've dropped in and on
where there are some Olympians
or like some guys that are in their twenties
who are training at a high level,
like I've noticed it's a lot different,
but still they're going to the pool,
they're training four hours a day.
So, It's still that being about 10,000,
By large 3000 meters,
you can get done in 45 minutes to an hour.
Right.
That's all the training you're doing in the pool a day
and not doing weights either,
super interesting.
And I think, look--
'Cause he is not doing weights.
I would say my era was too much volume,
Right.
Given that, you 100 butterfly, 48,9, 47 seconds,
you're gonna swim five hours a day.
Like do you really need that much endurance for that?
200 butterfly maybe a little bit more,
but still I was over-trained completely.
Yeah.
So, I think the pivot to being quality oriented
is appropriate but I still think
that you need that volume piece.
If you wanna be able to be dexterous and capable,
in events from the 100 to the 200.
And if you look at runners or you look at cyclists,
it's like every elite competitor is creating an aerobic base
and then building upon that.
And the fact that he's shirked out
it's interesting to look at it, but I don't know that...
I really think that he would have benefited
particularly in the 200 IM,
had he approached his training a little bit differently.
Phelps kind of called
that he, it would be interesting to see
if he can sustain it on his broadcast.
Michael Phillips has been very good on TV.
Incredibly good.
Yeah.
I mean, he crushed it.
He's been doing great and his hair looks fabulous,
his beard, is less fabulous.
There's a lot of fans for his beard,
his hair looks really good.
Yeah, I would kill for his hair, so, yes.
But I wouldn't.
but you know what?
We should bring our beards back in honor of Phelps.
He's been amazing.
Maybe, We'll see.
Yeah.
we'll see.
But yeah, he's got a big career in broadcast
and I think he's couldn't have been better.
He was fantastic.
But I still, much love for my boy, Rowdy Gaines.
Nobody gets more excited about these races than Rowdy.
The MVC played like they had a Camera on ROWDY,
Yeah, the ROWDY CAM.
Did you watch?
Yeah, I tweeted it earlier today.
Like, he's just losing his mind.
it's like a full body performance.
He's fabulous.
I know.
So, kudos to Rowdy Gaines,
kudos to Flora Duffy, the Bermudian native.
who won the triathlon.
Yeah, that was a cool story.
Who else?
Oh, did you see...
Well, lets talk about this Ryan Murphy thing.
Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
Did you see that?
like the after Rylov beat Murphy in the,
was it the 200?
I think he beat him in both.
Both 100 and 200?
Yeah, both backstroke.
So, I think it was tough for the 200 though.
That Murphy, they got on a diet together
and Murphy said something to the point of,
"I wish I could know."
I don't know that this was a fair race,
basically I don't know that Rylov is clean
because of the ROC thing that you're talking about.
Was there anything else that he knows
that we don't know though?
That's the question.
So, what have you heard?
Do you think swimming is clean?
I'm not close enough to swimming anymore,
to know for a fact
or to have any kind of educated opinion on that.
But I would suspect that there's probably some bad actors,
I think when you're watching the Tour de France
or you're watching Olympic Track and Field,
or you're watching swimming,
I think it's naive
to assume or presuppose that it's 100% clean
'cause there's always gonna be people
who are trying to get around that kind of stuff.
So, but I don't know to what extent,
there's any kind of doping going on, I've no idea.
So, I just don't have an informed opinion on it.
And what would it be--
Like, listen, and I don't know Ryan Murphy either,
but for him to say in a press conference
that he doesn't really accused Rylov,
but he kind of in a backhanded way is kind of accusing him.
He does accuse him.
So, makes you think that..
He say he doesn't but he does but he does.
Is that just because the RO...
Like the Russians found it non-runned
to nonetheless show up at the Olympics under this ROC thing,
or is there something specific to Rylov
that he knows Rylov was doing,
or he's heard rumors that we haven't heard
about something that was going on with him?
it makes me think there must be more to this
than just like, I'm pissed that the Russians
are here when they were actually banned.
There is something specific to Rylov,
Rylov is the guy that beat him twice.
Yeah, right, so of course,
In his mind, he's like,
"Wait, I could have got another gold medal.
So, you could say, well, it's our grapes,
or maybe he's like,
"This guy's been getting away with this shit
"for a long time," I don't know.
It's possible, the one thing I look at
when I think of performance enhancing drugs,
I think of body changes and muscles
and Rylov was surprisingly skinnier
than almost everybody up there.
And Murphy is like chiseled from stone.
Now,--
Murphy has quite a physique,
but the thing is doping doesn't really work that way.
Not blood doping, right?
No, blood doping doesn't work that way.
I would be surprised if it was blood doping,
where you're injecting yourself with other people's blood,
but EPO, basically these things allow you to train
harder and longer.
So, it creates a more robust training cycle.
So, it's not necessarily like something
that's gonna make you huge in terms of...
it's not like steroids,
where you're basically you're trying to improve
your body's ability to metabolize oxygen for energy.
And some people are more ectomorphic than other people.
So, Ryan Murphy, I think is just genetically predisposed
to look like a bodybuilder comparatively,
but just because the other guy Riley is skinny
and it's felt and has more of an endomorphic disposition
is not a reason to think he must not be doping.
No, no, no, right, right?
Murphy's a stud he,
yeah, who knows what Rylov is doing?
I'm not on the camp though,
just because Phobos film is amazing,
but I'm not here to think
that every Russian athlete is doping.
No, I don't know either who knows, who knows?
I think that that is,
that everyone has their internal,
I don't think every...
you can't make that judgment.
And I think there was some anger for losing
and it had to be something in there, yeah, who knows,
who knows, but that's what we're talking about.
Stuff we don't fully know about.
Yeah, So, we're just spinning opinions on stuff,
in a very half-baked way here.
There is one of the things that you wanted to discuss
that we should discuss.
And that is the new fitness fire,
that has corrupted in Tokyo.
This is wild.
Yes, should I go get them?
I'll go get them.
Yeah, go grab those things.
So, basically every Olympia, there's some crazy
technique or training philosophy that emanates out of it.
That that becomes like a story.
In the previous Olympics it was cupping.
Like you saw all the athletes walking around
with the kind of dark circles on their back
and on their shoulders,
this year, It's something called KAATSU,
KAATSU, KAATSU,
KAATSU
K-A-A-T-S-U.
Yes.
Which is basically this,
what do you call it?
Like a blood flow restrictor type thing,
like bands that you put around your extremities
to restrict blood flow,
that when used in training stimulate your hormonal system,
and your circulatory system to produce a result
that mimics training, right?
So, it's, yes...
That's a really bad way of describing that path.
The Idea is to make the circulatory system more elastic.
So, it's basically,
you're increasing plasticity of your capillaries
which allows, by restricting blood flow
and then letting it go.
So, it's like 30 seconds restricted,
five seconds let it flow and back and forth.
What you're doing is you're creating elasticity there,
which triggers the hormonal system
and the lymphatic response
to get rid of waste, basically,
metabolic waste, lactic acid.
You can flush that out.
It's essentially a tourniquet.
It's basically a torn...
So, originally, they--
But it doesn't completely restrict the blood flow.
You're not trying to cut it off completely.
Right, so, it is a tourniquet.
They used to be just bands that you could use
and maybe train that way.
In reality, the KAATSU,
these bands here that we have
that now there's a brand called KAATSU training
that Steven Munatones is involved with,
who is basically runs WOWSA,
the Open Water Swimming Association
is the number one chronicler of all things,
open water swimming.
I've known Steve forever,
and I did not know anything about this KAATSU thing.
So, in 2001, he met the guy who was using KAATSU,
Justin tourniquet form, just in bands, manually
with 20 people.
And one of them, he actually--
Dr. Sato, this Dr Sato guy.
And Steve, I guess, is fluent in Japanese.
Yes, apparently,
and so, he went and met with them in 2001, I guess it was.
And at that time there was a thought
that as you age, your muscles atrophy
and bone density diminishes,
and that's just the way it goes.
And there's nothing you can do about it.
Waits help to some degree.
That's why they ask older people to get into the gym
and do some weight resistance stuff and machines
to make sure you don't lose bone density.
He proved with these bands and his techniques
in an 104 year old woman, I believe it was.
He built bone density and 104 year old
using blood flow restriction.
And so, Steven got involved with him
and they developed a way
basically using kind of a blood pressure cuff technology
with air and pressure,
a way to make it automated so that you can use it.
And what Steven, there are a lot of the reporting,
there's been Futterman,
Matt Futterman at The New York Times, did a great story.
This was the first story.
Former podcast guest, always qualify.
Matt Futterman.
Yeah, he wrote this,
Who basically runs the sports desk.
Does he not?
What's his job specifically?
He was an editor and now he's mostly reporting these days,
He wrote this great article for The Time,
A Hot Fitness Trend Among Olympians: Blood Flow Restriction.
And he talks about this.
Which is, I don't know how I never heard about this.
I started looking into it.
Ben Greenfield actually did a whole podcast episode
about this, like a year ago.
And he had Steve on as a guest.
So, if you want to learn more, check that out.
But so, Steve told me
that it's actually better for recovery.
And so, he sent them to me
right before I did the Goggins 4 by 48.
'Cause he knew I had problems with my feet
and so, I use them then in between and I used--
How did this not show up as a show and tell earlier then?
I brought them once.
You did?
Yes, and then we forgot, or I forgot,
I forget what it was.
But so, I use them before and after, but mostly after.
And he says that the reason you do that is because it allows
so, people ice usually, if after a run,
if you have bad joints you ice,
after playing basketball, you ice.
Ice has been this thing that everybody tells you to do.
Physical therapists tell you, doctors tell you.
He saying ice, only what ice does is
it sends the blood back
and increases some sort of circulation or restricts
or increases circulation in some places.
But he said, it's very superficial.
The blood will only flush out very close to the skin
and it'll stay in the area.
What this does is it allows actual blood flow to restrict
and then reflow again.
And that allows you to really recycle the blood,
get that metabolic waste out of there.
And so, basically what happened was in 2001,
he met up with him and he created this thing
and still it was used to the general public,
but gradually Steve got more and more athletes interested.
The turned tide was, he got the Navy Seals interested.
So, Navy Seals started using it,
from there some NFL players started using it.
The first Olympian to use it was Carmelo Anthony,
the basketball player, in 2016,
he started to use it.
And then it leaked out from there.
And so, now it's basically
every single sport has someone using it.
All these professional sports franchises are using this.
Martial artists there.
It's like, I don't know I was today years old,
when I found out about this.
It's the new thing.
And he's saying it also helps with sleep.
So, what he told me today was
that you can use,
basically if you put it on right before sleep
or an hour before around your arms,
it will trigger a pair of the sympathetic response
in your body and it will help you get more into sleep.
Instead of melatonin, you can use KAATSU.
I've never tried it for sleep,
am gonna try it for sleep tonight.
But the other thing he said was that in such demand,
People are calling him from Tokyo.
To get that in Japanese inspired product.
Shipped to them.
And they basically, they are like,
they need to find product.
Luckily his main manufacturer in Korea
was smart enough to stockpile microchips.
He saw COVID happen,
and he knew there's gonna be a run on microchip somehow
like the one guy in the world that knew.
So, there is this In the Futterman piece,
there's also this character Dr. Jim Stray-Gundersen
Yes.
Who has become a big advocate of this.
He's a physician and a sports medicine researcher,
who's worked with Olympic organizations
in the U.S. and in Norway.
And he was the guy who pioneered
"Live high, train low", approach
which is this idea that
the best way to take advantage of altitude training
is to live at super high altitude
and then kind of go down the mountain and train at sea level
and then sleep, you know, high.
And that's how you get
the boost of oxygen carrying red blood cells, et cetera.
But apparently, Stray-Gundersen gets excited about KAATSU,
trained with Sato over the last decade,
becomes this KAATSU master.
And essentially is quoted in this article was saying,
"You can get the benefits of swimming 10,000 yards
"by swimming maybe a thousand."
Which goes to the point of Michael and Michael Andrew,
because Michael becomes this proponent of it
in his unique training philosophy and practices.
But Andrew also, what Futterman says in this article is that
he started experimenting with BFR, Blood Flow Restriction
five years ago at the urging of Chris Morgan quote,
"Veterans from Coach."
Chris is like an old friend of mine.
Remember why I shared about
going to the Monofin World Championships?
Like, He was on that team,
that's how I got to know Chris.
Chris has gone on to coach European national teams.
And then he was an assistant coach at Harvard.
Like he's a very,
he has a lot of really cool training philosophies
and methodologies, a good dude.
And maybe we can get Chris to come on
and talk about KAATSU a little bit more.
'Cause it sounds like Chris is sort of at the bleeding edge
of blood flow restriction.
I certainly want to know more about this.
It sounds a little bit like a panacea to me,
but can't get around the fact
that some of these athletes were using this
in preparation for Tokyo.
The idea was like wearing them on your arms
while you're swimming
or while you're in the gym lifting weights.
So, talking to him
and Antonio's on my drive here actually.
He kind of,
he didn't suggest that Futterman got it wrong
or anybody got it wrong.
He thinks all these athletes did their job well,
but his perspective is that recovery is the thing.
Recovery is really where it's gonna have the best effect
because you don't need to wear these bands and swim
like swimming is training for swimming,
not wearing my bands.
He's saying the bands should be worn in between.
So, sprinters use it.
Shikari who couldn't, because you got disqualified
after smoking marijuana, she uses them.
Let me see that slide that over here,
Gatlin uses them, the sprinter, Justin Gatlin--
You put, you put like--
So, I put it around my--
But what is this?
It connects with this guy?
So, there's a pump, part of it,
Yeah, It connects with this thing
and then you cycle it and you hear that,
it fills it over there.
Yeah.
Well, you know what?
During the photo session, we'll, we'll put some KAATSU on.
Yeah, I feel like an IV drug user.
That's what it is, it's like it's legit, tourniquet, right?
I don't know how this works.
I'm definitely doing this wrong.
It looks good on you.
We need an expert on here.
I'm still getting over the fact
that you've had this for a while
and I knew nothing it
I'm getting over the fact that I have had this for a while
and I could have broken the story before Futterman
and I missed my opportunity because I didn't see it.
You did all right, cool.
Bad report.
So,
You wanna say anything else about the Olympics?
look, I love the Olympics.
We could talk about this forever.
It is weird watching it with no spectators
and it's just, it's a strange time,
but I'm glad that these athletes are having this experience.
It must be so real for them to compete without audiences.
The whole thing is all very strange.
And I just, I love all things Olympics.
I grew up without Olympic dream myself,
and I've always just,
it's always just held a really special place in my heart.
So, I am a glorious kind of like fan and optimist
around all things, the Olympics,
while also knowing the IOC and all these organizations
are completely messed up.
I grew up knowing I had no chance
of ever being in the Olympics,
but I've always enjoyed watching him.
Well, you know what?
I love the comradery, I love the different nations.
I love the international appeal, the cultural exchange.
In this it's...
So, it really inspires me to see the cultural exchange,
to see the countries coming together.
And this year I've loved the hurdles out of nowhere.
Like I freeze frame,
like when you see a couple of them go over
and then the ones chasing,
and then when they're the ones behind are over
and then I pause it to see,
and everyone's off the ground all at once.
And it's just like.
Pretty cool.
The photography.
And speaking of photography,
I just wanna give a shout out
to a photographer I've worked with before Donald Miralle.
I think I pronouncing his name correctly.
I've worked with him on a story for ESPN.
He's a long time sports illustrated photographer,
a great prone paddler, based out of San Diego area.
And he has the best Instagram feed from Tokyo.
He's shooting for Nat Geo
and the stuff he's putting out there is just unparalleled.
So, I wanna link to that.
Yeah, am Looking at his Instagram right now,
it's pretty stunning.
Could be Donald Miralle.
Yeah, two Ls.
Donald Miralle, M-I-R-A-L-L-E,
however you pronounce that.
This picture of Caeleb Dressel with the traps, oh my God.
I mean, he's got pictures of the fencing.
That's incredible pictures of cycling.
The underwater photos are amazing.
He explains in one of his posts,
he was one of the innovators of underwater swimming photos.
So, he would go down there and set camera traps
before they had the track down there.
And now there's a track that everyone can have access to,
but he would go down there and set trap,
it set camera traps with a couple of other guys,
innovating it back, I guess 20 years ago.
And so, he's special
That's cool.
How do you feel about surfing and skateboarding
and all the new stuff?
I'll tell you this,
I love basketball three on three basketball
should not be an Olympic sport.
Yeah.
Like I'd rather see Foursquare or
like kickball, dodge ball.
I'm not into this X games meets the Olympics thing.
I never really went into it.
I think snowboarding is a great Olympic sport.
I'm not so sure about skateboarding and BMX.
How can you differentiate that?
How can you be okay with snowboarding
and not okay with skateboard or surfing?
You know what?
I'm okay with surfing too, to be honest with you
as an Olympic sport.
Are you just changing your,
how dare you change your mind in real time?
Adam.
I have an inner Tucker Carlson
that gives gets after me, constantly.
Yeah, I don't know where you draw the line with this.
Obviously, not everything should be included in the Olympic
shooting has been in the Olympics forever.
I think to me, the benchmark is always like thinking
about the original spirit of the Olympia
and what it was intended to be,
which was what I think you have to respond to culture.
And when like, everything is fluid,
just like languages isn't fix,
like these things are always changing.
I'm a huge baseball fan
and none of the real professional baseball players
are playing.
So, why is baseball in the Olympic?
I don't it's weird like that, right?
And soccer is the same way in the men's side.
So, with basketball you get the NBA guys,
but with baseball, you don't.
I don't think the Premier League guys
are playing in the soccer side.
I don't think so.
I don't think they're getting the Premier,
like it's not the World Cup team that's over there.
It's not the same.
So, it's just a different players.
Not in every case, yeah.
Yeah.
It's weird how that works.
It is weird,
ROC, I can't get over the, yeah, the ROC thing.
You want them really properly banned.
I'm such an old man that I remember the pain.
Like I knew people who made the 80 team
and how challenging that was when it was boycotted
and they couldn't go.
Well, now there's a boycott and they still go,
It's not a boycott, it's a band.
I mean a band, yeah, basically.
But the point being, if you're an athlete,
you don't get to go, right?
Yeah.
But they get to go.
Do you watch the Winter Olympics
the same way you watched summer?
Not as keenly.
Me neither.
Yeah, but maybe I think I will this year.
You will?
Yeah.
There's more people dressed head to toe in Lycra
in the winter Olympics, which I think is interesting.
Our swimsuits are not great.
The there's a lot of Lycra in the summer Olympics.
There's not a great,
our swimsuits have not been the most stylish
our costume are not great.
No.
Why does Ralph Lauren get appointed to design
the U.S. Olympic team uniform every time?
Because we couldn't find Levi-Strauss.
Are we all like, is the U.S. Olympic team
all living in Montauk?
Yeah, I want a 75 year old man, designing my clothes.
We need some freshness.
we need like, we need a designer.
We're going down the tubes here.
Let's get to some listener questions.
Let's do it, Justin from Minnesota.
Hey, Adam and Rich,
this is Justin from Minnesota.
So, my question for you guys
is you often hear that living an examined life is important
and doing the work is important as well,
but what is the work?
What is doing the work?
I'm struggling with this as I try
and find a way to reflect more and look at where I've been,
what I've done and what I want to do.
And I want to know what the work is
and what, how, where to begin
so that I can find a path forward and feel like I'm living
a more purposeful life.
I recently had twins and it's been a seismic shift
in the way things go in life, as you can imagine.
And so, I want to do the work on myself
to figure out how I can be a good father,
but also still achieve the goals and dreams
that I had free fatherhood, which is just as I put it,
been put on hold for the time being.
So, any advice on what to do for the work
to go deep on oneself, journaling, et cetera,
what to journal about all that kind of good stuff.
I would greatly appreciate it.
Thanks for everything you do, love the podcast.
Love you guys, talk later.
How van nice start is that question?
It's pretty essential.
I love it--
Essential list.
It's a great, this might be the best question ever asked
What is doing the work?
I love it,
Because you hear it all the time.
You hear well, he did the work.
Well, look at him, he did the work
or that guy's doing the work.
He's able to do this because he put the work in
and I found myself asking.
What is my work?
Everyone is doing, I don't understand,
and you feel like adult, like you don't wanna ask
because you don't wanna look stupid.
Right.
But no one is very detailed ever or specific
about what it is that that person actually did.
So, let's try to answer that.
I think there's no right or wrong answer.
There is no one way there is no one work.
I think the work is going to be different for every person,
depending your circumstances,
and you know what it is that you're trying to unlock
or reckoned with in your past or in your present.
But I think overall, the basic idea of around the work.
"The Work"
is engaging in some form of inward journey,
some form of some practice of self-examination
that It's motivated by a genuine intent
to better understand yourself objectively, honestly.
So, that you can have a greater sense of awareness around
not just what you're doing,
but why you're doing the things that you're doing.
Why you tell the stories that you continue to tell yourself
why you continue to repeat a certain behavior pattern,
even though, you know,
it's moving you in the wrong direction.
And I think the process of doing that,
the specific means by which you kind of unearth
your unconscious mind or confront your biases
or get objectively honest with your past
is through a variety of different modalities.
It can be seeing a therapist,
it could be seeing, you could be seeing psychoanalysis,
or it could be group therapy with a bunch of guys.
It could be a 12 step program, it could be journaling.
There was a specific question that Justin asked
about journaling, what kind of journaling?
Well, I think the kind of journaling
that you're more likely to do,
like it doesn't have to be any one way,
you could do morning pages out of the artist's way
where it's literally mumbo jumbo,
just to kind of clear the cobwebs in your mind.
Or it could be very intentional,
like trying to remember things
that happened to you in the past
so that you can make sense of them.
There is no right or wrong way.
The only Kind of objective,
correctness in all of it is that you are trying
like that you are moving inward in some way
that feels appropriate for you to make sense
of your interior life.
It could be reading books,
it could be having an accountability partner,
it could mean having a mentor who can reflect back to you,
the uncomfortable truth of your behavior.
it could involve creating a gratitude list
or any number of selfcare practices.
So, I don't know how helpful that is,
I certainly don't wanna leave Justin more confused.
But I think it just means commitment to one thing
or a number of things that are putting you
into greater contact with and understanding
of what makes you tick and why,
so that you can rewire whatever.
Inherent pathways are continuing to lead you
into directions you don't wanna go
and finding healthier outlets for your energy
that will set your life on a better trajectory.
What do you think?
I'm trying to figure out where his head space is
in terms of asking this question,
like to find a path forward
and feel like you're living a more purposeful life.
So, does that mean he's doing work
or doing a job that he's not feeling connected to?
Is he not feeling fully connected
to the purpose in his life?
'Cause, I think there's nothing more purpose
than two babies that showed up on your doorstep.
Well, that's the immediate need that has to be addressed.
I think he wants to connect something else to that.
'Cause they do feed each other, right?
If you feel fulfilled in one aspect of your life,
it can make you feel fulfilled on the other.
But my sense is that the twins thing
is so overwhelming that there's this lurking fear
that he's never gonna to be able
to execute on his other goals.
And you don't want to become the person
that just like is, doing a job
just because, just to pay bills
because bills need to be paid 'cause they do especially now.
So, I guess that's where my head goes.
I think you're right in terms of like just the whole idea
is just looking inward.
Maybe that's the first step,
doing the work can be a meditation practice.
It could be 10 minutes every morning,
sit down before you talk,
and just sit quietly for 10 minutes.
It's hard to do that when you got twins.
So, this guy's got twins,
this is gotta monopolizing his time.
So, he's not gonna be able to say, well, I'm gonna wake up,
and the first part of my day is gonna be quiet.
Like you're living your life, When you have young twins,
you're living your life reactively, which is not great.
Like I think it's more about like how to shift that valence
from being reactive to proactive,
but understanding that when you have twins,
it just is what it is, man.
And it's not always gonna be that way
and learning how to like flow with it rather than resist it
because you know that resistance
isn't gonna change your reality,
It's just gonna make you more miserable
because your life isn't meeting some,
fantastical expectation that you've set for it.
Just being okay with what is and carving out
whatever time you do have or those moments
in between everything else that you're doing
to find some kind of practice
that will help give you a little bit of peace,
clarity and objectivity.
I think accepting what is.
That's a huge--
It's like the first step, right?
Like to me, like you got to accept where you are
and who you are first,
and that's always the first step.
And so, there's ways of doing it quickly,
anything like going to therapy
or going to group therapy or journaling,
all that stuff is time intensive.
Yeah, of course,
Time is at a premium right now.
So, accepting self,
maybe coming up with some sort of a habit
or pattern that you can do with the kids,
like get them into a dual stroller and go for a run
or something like that for even 15, 20 minutes.
And just speak your mind into a recorder.
Anything like that you can do at the same time,
things like that,
just focusing the lens internally for some chunk of the day,
and it doesn't have to be long part of your day
is a good way to start.
You never know--
And of those overwhelmed moments,
I think having a gratitude practice is important.
Just write down five things you're grateful for,
to try to remember the big picture.
That's a great thing, you could do that every day.
Yeah, what a blessing it is that you have two healthy twins.
Yeah, but that's a great question.
It is a good question.
I hope we answered it sufficiently.
I don't think we did, but we're gonna move on now.
Okay, we're gonna do a less...
Well, it's just a more, just a different type of question.
This is a different kind of question, isn't it?
Yeah, Jess from the Open Road.
Hey guys, my name is Jess.
I I'm from Illinois originally, but I'm a travel nurse.
And so, I actually was last travel nursing
in the North Carolina and then it's Maine, next week.
So, I was curious as to a couple things.
So, top five bands from each of you
and then one or the other top five songs
or top five albums.
I would love to hear what you guys have to say about that.
I think that would be really interesting to hear.
Anyway, thank you so much, and take care.
I'll answer this question, but off the top of my head,
but I don't know that I'm glad
that Jess thinks that this will be interesting.
I don't know that anybody else
would think it was Interesting?
Come on, that it depends what you said.
You know, I was born in 1966.
I grew up in the seventies and eighties.
I think everybody when you go through
those adolescent years, those early teen years,
I don't know, 14 through 18 or 19,
something gets imprinted on you.
The music that you're listening at that time
becomes your favorite music.
That becomes like sort of anchored in you.
I don't think it changes much.
I grew up listening to, the big one for me is R.E.M,
I loved R.E.M, that changed what I thought music could be.
I fell in love with that.
When I was in college, I listened to a lot of English beat
and joy division and kind of new wave type stuff.
The Smiths.
The Smiths were a big one,
yes, with Hank Wise and the Smiths on the pool deck,
a bunch of like sky and a little bit of punk at the time.
Fish Bone.
I saw Fish Bone in concert many times.
But I love Wilco, Yankee Hotel Foxtrot
is like a perfect album.
I love Radiohead, Kid A, OK Computer,
or Unbelievable, for R.E.M.
I still love their earlier records, Murmur Reckoning.
I just think they're genius.
And if you're gonna have the conversation
about best bands and best albums,
you gotta throw the beetles in there.
Definitely.
Sergeant Peppers.
I love Jeff Buckley. I think his album Grace
is one that finds its way on the under
my recurring playlist.
I don't know, man.
What about you?
None of my top five would be bands that,
well, except for maybe one would be, or two,
that would be bands that I like.
I grew up that they were my favorite band at one point
and then never stopped.
The only exception would be my favorite,
which is Bob Marley and the Wailers was my favorite.
The minute I heard Bob and then has remained the top,
I think most important band for me.
But other than that I had like my first favorite band
was Talking Heads,
then I got into Bruce Springsteen
and then like later I got into hip hop
and now I'm mostly listened to jazz,
to be honest with you.
But the question I will give you my top five bands,
Bob Marley and the Wailers, David Bowie, Jimmy Hendrix,
John Coltrane would be my favorite jazz artists.
And then of course you gotta put the Beatles in there
because they're just groundbreaking.
Songs I would do "Tangled Up in Blue" by Bob Dylan,
"Exodus" by Bob Marley, "Heroes" by Bowie,
"Foodiechild" by Hendrix,
and "A Love Supreme,"
the whole album by Coltrane.
These selections are indicative of somebody who's maybe
five to 10 years older than you actually are, yeah.
This is entirely a squarely Gen X.
Are you even Gen X?
I am.
What year were you born?
'71.
Right so, I'm on the older spectrum
Am right in the middle Gen X.
But that doesn't mean,
what I was trying to say is that
I'm not one of those people that has top five bands.
I love all music and I love world music,
I love rock, I love all kinds.
So, for me, but if you had to pin me down
and I had to pick my top five bands,
like in the spirit of this, that's what I would say.
But in reality, I love all music.
I don't have a limit and it used to be that I did,
but I don't really anymore.
And some kind of open to all great music.
And my genre I listened to most
is jazz to be honest with you.
Should we just ditch everything that we've been doing?
And just talk about like music and movies on the podcast
from now on out.
You know what?
It's culture become some version of Chuck Klosterman.
I'm gonna wait until the next Google doc
and find out what I'm talking about.
Because you wanna talk about
whatever I wanna talk about Adam, don't you?
You know that is not true.
We had a whole thing of--
Do the work, are you doing the work Adam?
Of course not.
My whole philosophy is don't believe everything you feel,
which I know is bad.
That's probably not the philosophy, but it's my philosophy.
I don't think that that's bad
I think the caveat or the corollary to that,
that I would say is
that emotions are your body
and your interior consciousness,
trying to tell you something, right?
You can hid that message.
But I think we often over-index on those emotions
and then kind of make it all about that.
And the truth is a lot of challenging emotions feel like,
they're gonna kill you, I'm gonna die,
but emotions are always changing.
That's the one thing that you can always bank on.
It will always change, always change.
So, feelings are just like, they are sort of a corollary
is like feelings are just feelings.
You don't have to like, they don't have,
they feel like, they feel so real,
but essentially like you have a choice
how much you need to engage them.
Well, that's the whole idea with the stoicism versus
this new gen that worships mental health preservation.
Whereas that's where I depart from that
because I actually think there's a lot of,
I see a lot of people who are so into their mental health
and self care and this and that,
and they just become paralyzed.
Right, I can't go to work today, I have a,
I'm finding a little bit blue or whatever.
And it's like at some point
I'm not denigrating to go
about mental health issues, but now--
No, you have to reconcile, appropriately reconcile,
responsible care for mental health,
with the importance of developing
a little bit of emotional resilience.
Yes.
So, yes.
Yes, all right, Let's do the last question.
Last question.
I have this laptop here
and I keep putting my finger on the screen
thinking it's an iPad laptop.
You wanted to go laptop today.
I know.
Well, because it's just better with opening links
and there were some articles I want to show.
Okay, let's hear from Bev.
Hi, Rich and Adam.
This is Bev from Denver, Colorado.
I've had a long running career
that includes three Bostons while in my 50s.
My first Boston was the year of the bomb
and the only marathon I didn't finish.
Anyway, I'm 66 years old now,
and I'm having difficulty accepting the fact
that I'm not as fast as I was
and my feet can't take the longer distances.
My question is how to deal with the hard facts of aging
and still set realistic goals that excite me for the future.
Some days it's a real, emotional and physical challenge.
Thanks for any insights.
Bye.
Thank you, Bev.
I feel a little insecure trying to answer this question.
Given the fact that Bev is like 11 years older than me.
So, she probably has more wisdom and experience
about aging than I do.
But my instinct, my first gut reaction to that question
is that comparison is the thief of joy.
And I think it's unrealistic and unfair
to compare yourself at 66
to the way that you used to be able to run.
I don't know how back into your,
in far back into your history, your casting your gaze,
but essentially it goes to the answer
to the previous question,
which is about acceptance like first,
accept that you're 66 years old right now,
like, let go of this idea,
stop measuring yourself against where you used to be
or think you should be, right?
Like you're 66, there's certain realities about that.
You'll probably share my musical tastes, for instance.
Probably, how it's suspected she does.
So, you can talk about Hendricks and Coltrane.
But the idea that you're comparing yourself
and judging yourself,
like you're creating trauma for yourself
by judging yourself against a younger version.
I don't know what age are you looking at?
25?
45?
50?
It's unclear, but essentially you're setting yourself up
to be disappointed because you're 66
and you're not gonna be able to run as fast as you did
when you were in your 50s or 40s clearly.
So, I think the best way to like reckon with all of that
is to make peace with it,
to train where you're at and focus on
where you can find the joy in all of it.
You could still set goals and those goals should be,
difficult, something you you're going to strive for,
but also realistic, given the fact that you know you're 66.
And just try to be the best 66 year old version of yourself,
because comparing yourself doing pass self
again, is a comparison that robs you of joy.
It's a thief of joy.
And honestly like truth talk for a minute here.
Does anybody give a shit how fast you run at 66?
No one cares.
The only person who probably cares is you.
And it's important that you care, that's great,
but the weight that you're putting on your times
and all of that I think is playing into this heaviness
that you're experiencing around running.
So, why not alleviate yourself of that pressure.
Go zone two baby, go zone two
and leaving the times behind.
Right, like holding onto,
I can't run as fast as I used to.
Like, is it worth it holding onto that
for the kind of frustration that it's causing you?
the consternation, what about running makes you happy?
And orienting your goal around that I think is a better aim
of your intentionality.
Love it.
If it's a performance
that gets you out of bed in the morning unexcited,
then again, you can set a goal.
There's nothing wrong with setting a performance goal,
but don't set the goal you would have set for yourself
at age 40.
Just remember if you signed up for that 10k right now,
there are a bunch of athletes running around an oval
that can do a 10k in 24 minutes.
Yeah, it's shocking.
So, what are we talking about here?
Like, what is it that got you
falling in love with running to begin with,
and maybe find other ways that are not performance related
to find joy in it.
Like the travel, like going to a race it's in a cool place
or training with a community of people
or meeting new people, et cetera.
There's so much, there's so much richness
in the sport of running
that it doesn't all have to be about like PRs
I got two words for you, Bev, KAATSU.
KAATSU, that's right,
she's gonna be all about KAATSU.
And swim run.
Yeah, but that's gonna get her all excited
that maybe she PR marathon.
If she starts putting tourniquets all over her body.
KAATSU, yes, she's KAATSU.
She's gonna call up Steve Munatones.
Get on the KAATSU and then go to wild swimrun camp,
where they get women of all ages together
and do swimrun camps
where you can not worry about your time so much,
'cause you're going to also be integrating
some open water swimming and believe me,
there are women of all ages,
there are definitely women in your age group--
There's no indication in Bev's question
that she has any interest in swimming whatsoever.
Did I mention swimrun?
Yeah, you did.
Oh, am I not?
It's my advise,
You had to bring in swimrun.
You had to bring swimrun into this.
Even when the podcast has nothing to do with swimrun,
there goes, Adam, bring it up swimrun again.
And you're a shill for big swimrun
for the low tide boys, are sending you checks.
You can't do a marathon, have you thought of swimrun?
That's all I'm saying.
Okay.
Do we answer this question?
I think we need to end this.
All right, let's put a cap on it.
Let's land this plane.
Let's do that, how do you feel?
I feel like I didn't deliver on these questions
to be quite honest with you, but you know,
it's an emotion and I'll get over it.
Right, it's impermanent.
Feelings are just feelings.
These Olympics are gonna end
Do you need to take a mental health day?
(Adam laughing)
Do I look like I can take?
No, like, yeah, if you would like, the next "Roll On."
I get a phone call in the morning.
which I can't record it.
Well, I can't do it.
Yeah.
I can't do it, I've been (indistinct) to launch.
That feels snarky.
Well, I didn't say it, you said it.
No, I'm reflecting on myself.
Like I literally, we do need greater appreciation
for the nuances of mental health
in the workplace and in this forum.
I feel like between the two of us,
you're more into the like mental health camp.
I am more into the try not to think about it camp.
Yeah, it's a challenge
because you do need emotional resilience,
you need to develop the capacity for showing up
when things are hard and you don't wanna show up.
So, where do you strike that balance?
That's really where the question lies.
I think when the Jews were wandering desert for 40 years,
there were the curvatures,
and then there were the people like me
that are just like, try not to think about it.
I wasn't trying not to think about it Jew.
I was not a curvatures Jew,
I was trying not to think about a Jew
That's what I am, I'm the trying not to think about a Jew.
A very specific type.
Subset.
Yeah.
I'm a subset of the desert people.
You don't wanna sit around and talk about it
all the permutations.
Not only do I not wanna talk about it,
I don't wanna hear you talk about it (laughing).
No one wants to hear it anyway.
All right, I don't know what we're doing,
Let's end this, all right?
Listen, thank you, Adam, that was fun.
Thank you.
I don't know what we did today, but we did something.
We wore tie-dye.
You did?
Yes.
If you would like your question answered
in a haphazard and perhaps not helpful way,
leave us a voicemail, 424 2354 626.
Show notes on the episode page at richroll.com,
links to all the stuff we talked about.
Like Matt Futterman's article
in The New York Times, et cetera, are all on the website.
You can check that out there.
Dive deeper into everything we discussed today.
Please hit the subscribe button on YouTube,
Apple and Spotify, wherever you listen to the show.
And that's it.
Call, leave us some questions guys.
Yeah, leave us some good ones.
Yeah.
I wanna thank everybody
who helped put on the show today,
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering production
show notes, interstitial music, calendaring.
I don't know, taking care of the...
Like he does all kinds of stuff here, lots of stuff.
Thank you Jason
He stops people from sawing outside our doorway.
He does.
Yes, he's Johnny on the spot.
When there's a noise outside,
he runs outside and rectifies it.
Post haste.
Post haste,
Blake Curtis for videoing and editing the podcast.
It's a lot of work, thank you, Blake.
He's the one who makes all of this look so cool.
Jessica Miranda for graphics.
Today we have--
Grayson.
Grayson Wilder on portraits, thank you, Grayson.
Georgia Whaley for copywriting DK,
for advertiser relationships.
Theme music by my boys, Tyler Trapper and Harry.
Appreciate all of you.
I don't take your attention for granted,
and I'll see you back here in a couple of days
with another awesome episode.
We have Courtney Dauwalter up this week, just went up.
I think who's going up in a couple...
I think it's Eric Adams.
Really?
New York City's next mayor.
Incredible.
Yeah, man.
Runners, mayors.
All kinds of people.
Bruce Friedrich, clean meat.
Out of work journalists, you get them all.
All right, man,
I need a two week break from you.
I'll see you in two weeks.
Are we in a timeout right now?
No, we're not in the timeout.
Well, I guess we are in a timeout.
We're gonna hit timeout and we'll see you in two weeks.
I'm gonna talk to other people while--
Are you?
You're not allowed.
That's not part of our contract.
All right, man, love you.
You too, man.
Peace, plants.
Bye bye (indistinct).